Québec offre gratuitement la vaccination
contre la grippe à l'ensemble de la
population dès aujourd'hui jusqu'à
maintenant le Québec c'est la seule
province canadienne qui ne l'offrait pas
à tout le monde Benoit président de
l'association des pharmaciens
propriétaires du Québec il est là pour
nous en parler bonjour monsieur Morin
alors de votre point de vue au niveau de
vos organisations est-ce que ça va
changer quelque chose que ce soit
universel et gratuit
simplifier les choses parce qu'il
fallait un peu crier les gens lorsqu'il
venaient pour se faire vacciner donc
vous ferez retourner quelques personnes
qui n'étaient pas éligibles ou qui
devait défrayer les coûts de la
vaccination donc ça simplifie maintenant
tout le monde a accès et étant donné de
la circulation des virus de l'intensité
justement de croissante de l'influenceur
covid toujours présent
qui circule beaucoup la prévention reste
l'âme de prédilection pour se prémuner
contre les infections plus graves
finalement les pharmaciens vous êtes
devenus des entrepreneurs vous
connaissez bien les principes de
vaccination parce que avec ce qu'on a
connu avec la covid alors je présume que
déjà c'était en place pour la
vaccination antigrippale vous aviez déjà
commencé à remplir les calendriers alors
est-ce qu'il va falloir changer la
cadence selon vous accroître peut-être
le nombre de personnels pour vacciner
inoculer les gens
je vous dirai de prolonger la campagne
faire probablement c'est à dire que on a
déjà une bonne partie quelques semaines
ou ça roule bien on a vacciné au dessus
de quelques centaines de mille de
patients qui sont venus en pharmacie
mais ça va prolonger étant donné que
c'était léger étant donné que les virus
circulent le temps des fêtes d'arrivent
on voit qu'il y a une certaine
engouement pour la Corée 19 et il
devrait en avoir un pour l'influenza
aussi étant donné qu'on l'éteint bien
qu'il faut encore préciser que ces
préférable de prioriser les groupes à
risque en nous ce qu'on souhaiterait
c'est d'augmenter la vaccination des
groupes à risque et finalement de
l'étendre à tout le monde c'est bien
mais d'abord si vous êtes à risque si
vous êtes vous souffrez de maladie
chronique déficit immunitaire c'est
important de vous faire vacciner parce
que les risques de complications de
l'influenceurs sont plus grands à ce
moment-là mais donc nous on est bien
rodé la vaccination rôle pour la covid
influenza ça fait partie de nos
opérations quotidiennes pour majorité
d'entre nous donc il y a pas de il y a
pas de défi supplémentaire si vous
voulez
à continuer la campagne allez vous jouer
un genre de rôle proactif c'est à dire
les gens qui se présentent pour le
l'anti grippal est-ce que on va leur
demander en passant avez-vous la dose de
rappel pour le covid-19 on pourrait vous
vacciner dans le même bras ou dans les
deux bras les deux vaccins
les vice versa des gens qui viennent
pour la covid ont offre l'influenceur
aussi
on s'assume tout le monde a un petit
réserve de test rapide aussi pour se
tester donc on fait un peu tout ça en
même temps ça permet de
d'avoir ce qu'il faut pour pour prévenir
prévenir la transmission la complication
les complications donc oui on va l'offre
de façon systématique bien qu'on préfère
quand les gens s'annoncent qui réservent
leurs plages pour les deux vaccins qui
le spécifient dans l'excenté il y a une
option pour le spécifier ça permet de
préparer les équipes de pas avoir de
retard et de rendre l'opération là plus
douce pour tout le monde bon c'est ce
que j'allais vous demander donc pour
prendre rendez-vous dans une pharmacie
il faut quand même il faut tout de même
aller sur le clic santé et c'est là
qu'on voit même quelle pharmacie peut
avoir de la place peut-être pas que
c'est chez vous ça sera chez un autre
mais on pourra avoir un rendez-vous en
pharmacie sur l'excent
c'est c'est parti vous allez être occupé
j'allais dire jusqu'à Noël mais je pense
ça va être jusqu'au de Noël alors merci
Monsieur
c'est comme les deux dernières années en
effet merci beaucoup à la prochaine
bonne journée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI